d'après les premiers éléments d'enquêté
les normes de sécurité semblent avoir
été respectée au parc astérix ou un
enfant de 6 ans s'est noyé hier
le garçonnet est tombé d'une grosse
bouée à bord de laquelle ils avaient
pris place avec un groupe de personnes
pour des va lire une rivière ponctuée de
cascades d'ormuz et de geysers
l'attraction a été placé sous scellés
franck petit inchangé après avoir été
brièvement pris en charge par une
cellule psychologique
les enfants repartent chez eux en
belgique escorté par les motards de la
gendarmerie des petits de 6 ans choquée
par les événements de l'après midi l'un
des leurs julien est passé par dessus
bord alors qu'il profitait de cette
attraction filmé ici en 2004
l'accident s'est produit à 15h38 il aura
fallu près de 20 minutes pour retrouver
le garçonnet et qu'on a su que l'enfant
était alors on a on s'est précipité tous
ceux qui étaient sur place
aussi les opérateurs qui s'occupe de
l'attraction que que l'encadrement qui
n'est jamais très très loin à sauter
directement pour essayer de retrouver
et puis de le remonter à la surface puis
possible et donc l'eau était trouble qui
on n'a pas trop vu tout fait trop de la
part trouvé tout de suite
malheureusement et c'est un c'est au
pied d'un de la traction à la
dans dans l'eau on l'a pas retrouvée
depuis lolo n'est pas effectivement les
parents du petit julien sont arrivés
hier à l'hôpital de creil où a été
transporté leurs enfants à l'entrée du
parc astérix le règlement intérieur
précise que la direction engage vivement
les parents à ne pas laisser les enfants
de moins de 12 ans sans la surveillance
d'un adulte
à défaut sa responsabilité ne saurait
être engagée malgré tout une enquête
pénale a été ouverte par le procureur de
senlis
y at il eu défaut de surveillance de la
part des adultes qui encadraient les
enfants les procédures de sécurité
ont-elles fonctionner correctement pour
l'ensemble des investigations se
poursuivent beaucoup d'auditions eu
d'amour puisque avait beaucoup de
personnes présentes pour définir les
circonstances de ce drame
en attendant les résultats de l'enquêté
la traction qui existe depuis
l'ouverture du parc a été mise sous
scellés